[Musique]
bonjour premier numéro du 7 8 sociétés
sur tv 60,18 ce nouveau numéro nous vous
rendez vous mensuel qui vous permettra
d'aborder autrement l'actualité à
travers tout d'abord la diffusion d'un
documentaire inédit sur notre antenne et
ensuite à travers une discussion en
plateau avec des invités en ce mois
d'octobre nous allons parler
d'environnement changement climatique le
défi énergétique c'est le thème de cette
émission à laquelle participent à
l'amazone bonjour du laboratoire des
sciences du climat de l'environnement de
l'université de saint quentin en
yvelines et puis également frédéric
vincent bonjour bonjour vous êtes
membres d'alternative à versailles un
mouvement qui s'est lancé pour réagir
notamment face au défi du changement
climatique pour l'instant je vous
propose de découvrir ce document de
claire jeanteur elle a suivi bertrand
piccard a dans la préparation de son
tour du monde un tour du monde pas comme
les autres avec un avion fonctionnant
uniquement à l'énergie solaire bertrand
piccard la trajectoire et l'altitude une
production beau travail ushuaïa tv et tv
tel bravo syria bravo
conte du mois
l autre
[Musique]
tout avec what we need to bâtiment
et
[Musique]
nous avons décidé de commencer notre
tour du monde à abou dhabi ce qui nous
permet d'un côté de passer l'un très tôt
dans la saison avant les moussons mais
aussi abou dhabi s'impose de manière
logique à cause de sa diversification
dans les énergies renouvelables
donc c'est vrai que sur le ring cause
l'avion solaire qui décolle depuis abu
dhabi et ça ça a du sens
cyrano de bergerac disait mon témoin au
certes mais sol
et je pense que c'est exactement
l'inversé qu'il faut faire il faut
montre plus haut mais à deux ou à
plusieurs et
et
me
[Musique]
ambre et d'albert j'ai une bonne
nouvelle pour vous je vous donne le go
or le départ de solar impulse
et puis c'est plus avion depuis la
vienne litres d'alcool merci vous
prendrez des bons vol surtout bon soleil
c'est vrai
la pénurie
[Applaudissements]
à chaque vol c'est chaque fois
l'impossible qui reculent
et ça c'est une satisfaction
extraordinaire ça c'est les chromos nord
premier set 8 sociétés pour cette saison
sur tb s 78 nous parlons ce soir du
changement climatique plus
particulièrement du défi énergétique qui
se pose afin d'endiguer ce phénomène en
plateau donc un hommage aussi vous venez
de nous rejoindre du laboratoire des
sciences du climat de l'environnement de
l'université de versailles saint quentin
vous êtes la paléoclimatologue pour être
très précis
et puis également frédéric vincent
membre d'alternatiba à versailles ce
mouvement je le disais au tout début de
cette émission créée pour réagir face
notamment au défi du changement
climatique
peut-être un regard sur ce défi de
bertrand piccard qui a placé laventure
technologique au service de la planète
vous avez suivi peut-être j'imagine ce
défi de traverser la planète avec
uniquement l'énergie solaire oui je les
suis bas comme citoyen mais moi je
trouve ça extraordinaire et je trouve
que c'est comment dire un exemple pour
l'avenir des développements des
nouvelles technologies évidemment ce
n'est qu'un point de départ est de
montrer que disons on arrive à faire
voler un avion et qu'ils fassent le tour
de la terre ce qui est quand même le
vraiment quelque chose difficile je
dirais uniquement avec l'électricité
produite sur place c'est-à-dire en
volant par les panneaux solaires
je trouve ça extraordinaire et
prometteur évidemment ça veut pas dire
que demain on va monter dans des a380
électrique et ça montre quand même ce
qu'on peut faire et disons c'est un
optimisme qui est dans ce superbe projet
ce superbe succès que vous partagez ce
pont de l'optimisme qui s'en dégage pour
l'avenir oui auxerre que c'est
enthousiasmant de voir un progrès
technologique
mais il faut tempérer ce à dire qu'il ya
d'autres façons de faire il faut pas
tout miser sur la technologie donc le
progrès technologique c'est bien mais il
ya aussi d'autres façons de faire et
c'est ce qu'on va voir avec vous allez
nous dire justement là proches que vous
pouvez avoir de ces changements
peut-être de comportement aussi tout
simplement et pas uniquement tout
reposer sur la technologie ce sera
l'objet de cette émission du 7-8 société
aujourd'hui alors vous travaillez sur la
paléoclimatologie c'est la science qui
étudie les climats passés leurs
variations les phénomènes auxquels on
assiste aujourd'hui pour revenir un
petit peu parce que c'est la base de
tout ça tout ce qui est tempêtes
tornades réchauffement climatique
ce qu'il y a des précédents où est-ce
qu'on peut directement impactés sur
l'activité humaine aujourd'hui toutes
les conséquences de ce qu'il ya des
précédents évidemment fin mai ce qui se
passe c'est que ce qui est possible si
vous voulez c'est que le nombre de ces
tempêtes peut-être sera augmentée dans
le futur leur intensité peut être aussi
les impacts par contre on est quasiment
sûr que ce sera plus graves notamment
lié à l'élévation du niveau de la mer
donc les régions côtières seront plus
vulnérables aussi au fait qu'il ya plus
en plus de monde qui habitent sur les
côtes
donc voilà il y en a eu dans le passé ça
dépend si on regarde le passé des
derniers siècles ou le passé plus
lointain d'ailleurs
dans le passé il y en aura un futur mais
il est très probable que comment dire le
réchauffement climatique va changer
aussi bien la fréquence et l'intensité
de certains de ces événements
pas forcément tous et il est à peu près
sûr que les impacts seront plus grave
parce que en même temps il ya le niveau
de la mer qui augmente à cause du
réchauffement climatique aussi et
l'activité humaine la responsabilité de
l'homme aujourd'hui sur la situation à
ben elle est directe ainsi vous voulez
le réchauffement climatique de ces
dernières dizaines d'années est dédié à
l'utilisation massive des combustibles
fossiles et l'effet de serre qui
augmente et on a abusé dans les énergies
polluantes abuser c'est peut-être pas le
mot mais enfin le résultat est donc en
augmente l'effet de serre en utilisant
de façon massive le pétrole le charbon
et le gaz
d'un autre côté ça nous a apporté au
sens très générale un confort
voilà on vit bien mieux qu'avant quand
il ya 50 100 200 300 ans
mais ça a ses limites aussi en utilisant
de nouvelles technologies en changeant
aussi peut-être les comportements on
peut inverser le cours des choses
en tout cas le limiter l'impact plutôt
limité l'impact le modéré c'est à dire
de toute façon il faudra
de l'adaptation mais l'adaptation sera
plus facile au réchauffement et des
conséquences sont modérés que si on
continue et que les choses divergent
davantage donc on va voir sur le
changement de comportement la façon dont
alternative à appréhender chose juste
une petite pause pour regarder ce
reportage les représentants de deux vd
comme institut qui travaille sur les
technologies de demain pour les
véhicules n'a pas pu venir sur le
plateau aujourd'hui
mais l'institut vd comme l'institut pour
la transition énergétique qui est basée
dans les yvelines du côté de satory a
fêté récemment ses trois ans il ya de
nombreuses innovations qui ont encore
été présentée je propose de regardez ce
reportage
la voiture que nous conduiront demain et
probablement en phase d'élaboration ici
à satory l'un des sites où est basé vd
comme l'institut pour la transition
énergétique et créer en 2014 travaille
actuellement sur près d'une vingtaine de
projets et profite de son troisième
anniversaire pour les faire découvrir à
ses partenaires nous disons que nous
voulons être l'écosystème qui génèrent
ces nouvelles mobilités l'écosystème de
référence et nous voulons être les
pionniers de ces nouvelles mobilités vd
comme compte désormais 150
collaborateurs pour développer ces
différents axes de recherche comme
l'électrification des véhicules
objectifs permettent de réduire la
consommation d'énergie et les émissions
de polluants principe à l'inauguration
cette année la piste qui recharge
directement la batteries des voitures
électriques
on peut l'imaginer au travers de la
charge en roulant qu'elle soit continu
comme on le fait sur la piste fabrique
coupe ce soit en biberonnage c'est à
dire avoir des spots où on charge quand
on s'arrête on peut effectivement
imaginer se déplacer sans consommer
d'énergie sur la batterie doté d'un
budget de 25 millions d'euros annuels bd
comme poursuit son développement l'an
prochain l'ensemble de ces activités
seront rassemblés à satory dans des
nouveaux locaux
la changement climatique le défi
énergétique c'est la question que nous
abordons aujourd'hui dans le 7-8 société
quel regard vous portez sur ces
innovations technologiques vous disiez
tout à l'heure il faut pas tout miser
dessus mais en tout cas ça va dans le
bon sens alors c'est intéressant tout à
fait après c'est la question c'est
comment ça va être mis au service de la
société et donc
alternatiba en fait c'est un mouvement
enfin elle ça veut dire alternative en
basque vous a fait la promotion des
alternatives face au réchauffement
climatique mais aussi l'épuisement des
ressources naturelles qu'on chaque année
nous consommons trop de ressources
naturelles comme le bois le les poissons
il ya l'épuisement des sols et en fait
ça vise à faire prendre conscience qu'il
ya d'autres façons de faire et que ce
sont des façons de faire qui sont
enthousiasmantes qui sont joyeuses et sa
concrètement ça peut être une changement
dans des pratiques de l'alimentation ça
peut être participé à une association de
maintien pour l'agriculture paysanne ce
qu'on appelle les amap ce qui permet de
recréer une agriculture à taille humaine
plus local avec ce beaucoup moins
l'utilisation d'intrants de pesticides
et donc on ne revient à une agriculture
qui ne dépend plus du pétrole puisque
actuellement en asie
on dépend d'une agriculture très
industrielle qui tissent beaucoup de
de pétrole pour les tracteurs ou pour
les différents intrants ça peut être
aussi bas dans l'énergie c'est à dire
changer les comportements
donc à
les différents scénarii qui ont été
mises en avant par l'association
d'ingénieurs qui s'appelle négawatt et
l'ademe agence de l'environnement est
triste de l'énergie qui perd qui
montrent qu'il est possible de sortir
des énergies fossiles et du nucléaire
d'ici 2050 avec trois axes de
développement la sobriété l'efficacité
et les énergies renouvelables
la sobriété ça consiste à changer de
comportement c'est à dire que moi j'ai
par exemple les pros - prendre l'avion
je vais j'y vais pas je vais arrêter de
je vais pas aller ont chaque année en
vacances aux seychelles
l'effet sur une réflexion vraiment
profonde du même du mode de
fonctionnement et de consommation du
quotidien en fait je devrais dans cette
pratique même tout est parti en vacances
je vous disiez et est ce qui empêche pas
partis en vacances et skip empêche pas
de prendre l'avion une fois de temps en
temps ça peut être aussi donc
l'efficacité c'est plus bas vous avez un
vote bâtiment votre logement vous avez
isolés thermiquement ce qui fait que
vous allez consommer moins d'énergie
pour le chauffage et les énergies
renouvelables
c'est ce qu'on a c'est les énergies de
flux c'est c'est l'énergie hydraulique
c'est les éoliennes c'est le
photovoltaïque c'est de la biomasse est
donc en combinant ces trois axes il est
possible en fait de sur quelques
décennies de sortir des énergies
fossiles et du nucléaire évidemment ça
va prendre du temps mais c'est faisable
et donc l volet alimentation et elle
voulait énergie il ya si le volet
économie l'utilisation des objets par
exemple les ressourceries comme plutôt
que de jeter un objet on peut lui donner
une seconde vie via une ressourcerie
c'est emmaüs c'est un exemple de
ressourcerie mais on a d'autres
il ya le volet que les ailes volet
démocratie comment remettre de la
démocratie alternatiba saint
fonctionnement horizontale avec une
gestion par consentement et ça marche on
arrive à le faire marcher
et puis aussi le volet éducation il est
important d yeux bat 2 comment dire de
porter attention aux enfants
est-ce qu'ils reproduisent pas des
comportements qui peuvent être nuisibles
en fait ça peut être ya plein de choses
c'est à dire faire et vite et on est
dans des addictions
on a une addiction au pétrole on a une
addiction à la surconsommation
on a certaines addictions et donc dont
il faut se libérer en fait alternatiba
je le précise mouvement vous parliez de
la traduction en basse que justement qui
a été lancé à bayonne en 2013
voilà on a aussi sur la petite
présentation de leur expliquer le nom
alternatiba voilà oui exactement
merci le d'en parler donc effectivement
ça a commencé à bayonne en 2013 et qui
regarde premier festival des
alternatives qui je crois 12 mille
personnes depuis plus d'une centaine de
villages qui ont accueilli plus de 500
mille personnes et à versailles nous
avons créé un collectif
il ya plus d'une cinquantaine de
bénévoles a déjà plusieurs centaines de
personnes qui sont intéressées je pense
que nous avons quelques milliers de
personnes
donc ce sera dimanche 15 octobre sur le
parvis de l'hôtel de ville et à
l'intérieur est d'ailleurs une bonne
conversion la mairie de versailles qui
est un partenaire donc le bal le
meilleur français de mézières et tous
ces services techniques toutes les
équipes qui avec nous travaillons et qui
nous permettent à disposition
différentes ressources et qui fait que
ben il ya une super dynamique avec le 15
octobre organiserait c'est sur le parvis
de l'hôtel de ville c'est ça alors il y
aura en quoi je crois qu'il ya 80
intervenants
c'est dur à des ateliers des conférences
des spectacles il y aura des animations
ce sera donc à la fois pédagogique et
ludique pour tous les âges et voilà donc
ça va être bien cette logique de changer
les mentalités les façons de faire je me
tourne vers vous le chercheur de
scientifique mais peut-être aussi vers
le citoyen quel regard vous portez sur
le travail qui est mené sur ce
changement de même de conception vous
disiez pour évoluer dans le tout sans
tomber dans l'angélisme d'ailleurs je
pense que toutes les initiatives qui
permettent de prendre conscience de
réfléchir d'essayer d'agir sont bonnes
et effectivement à l'occasion de la fête
de la science est un excellent moment
je voulais aussi rebondir sur l'aspect
comportement et technologies je pense
que les deux vont ensemble
les progrès technologiques les
aménagements permettent de changer les
comportements sans que ce soit une trop
grosse contrainte quand par exemple sur
le plateau de saclay bas petit à petit
il ya des pistes cyclables de kate
qualité que l'on ne risque plus d'être
écrasés par les voitures à tout moment
eh bien on n'hésite pas à prendre le
vélo ou le vélo électrique s'il ya des
côtes
donc je pense que les aménagements la
technologie et les comportements
tout ça ça va ensemble vous parlez des
vélos justement on va peut-être regardez
ce reportage aussi parce que pour unir
courage et ses initiatives l'a50
franciliens se lancer un défi au cours
du mois de septembre
trois semaines sans voiture s'était
organisée par la mairie de paris avec
l'objectif de se passer de son véhicule
et n'utiliser que des transports de
substitution et nous avons suivi à l'un
de ses candidats à ce défi lui fait de
trajets tous les matins pour venir
travailler à guyancourt à saint quentin
en yvelines
ce geste c'est devenu une habitude pour
florent prendre le train déplier son
vélo électrique une routine installé
depuis une semaine
comme une cinquantaine de participants
il s'est lancé dans le défi trois
semaines sans voiture j'adopte la
multimodalité
donc c'est à dire que je prends mon je
prends mon vélo de chez moi jusqu'à la
gare montparnasse
ensuite je prends un jeu pour le ter qui
arrive à la gare de versailles chantiers
ici et ensuite je réutilise ce vélo donc
qui est électrique pour faire les 8
derniers kilomètres qui me sépare de mon
travail donc en transport je mettais à
peu près une heure dix ou quinze ans
voiture une heure vingt à peu près par
par trajet donc fois dessus aujourd'hui
là avec le vélo train vélo je mets à peu
près 55 9 un gain de temps et une source
de pollution en moins
le vélo électrique permet aussi de moins
se fatiguer il est prêté par
l'association we move partenaires de
l'opération
les coaches reste en contact avec les
candidats pour se soutenir et régler les
différents problèmes rencontrés malgré
un souci de crevaisons et une panne
florent reste convaincu j'hésitais déjà
avant le défi je me posais la question
est là le fait de n'avoir un an près
pendant trois semaines a fini de me
convaincre et ça va donner un maître
futurs investissements
dès que le porte-monnaie le permet pour
ce type de modèle il faudra compter dans
les 800 euros certains peuvent aller
jusqu'à 2000 la mairie de paris
organisatrice du défi offre une
subvention pour les acheteurs initiative
qui a dû vous séduire oui c'est un bel
exemple d'une belle utilisation de la
technologie non cotées voilà le progrès
technologique oui après il faut trouver
le bon curseur j'en reviens juste au
documentaire qu'on a vu au début de
cette émission sur le travail de
bertrand piccard utiliser l'énergie
solaire uniquement pour se déplacer ce
sera une solution serait envisageable
possible on va voir de toute façon il
n'y a pas de solution miracle il faut
toujours penser
disons en quelque sorte à utiliser tous
les leviers qui sont à notre disposition
et les utiliser de manière optimale en
fonction de ce qu'on veut faire
je voulais rebondir un peu sur deux
reportages je vais vous dire c'est une
très belle illustration mais je ne
savais pas qu'il y avait ce reportage
voilà donc vraiment y'a pas de solution
miracle et la transition s'est vraiment
en jouant sur tous les leviers qui
seront à notre disposition ça je le
pense profondément avec
vous travaillez sur la constitution des
variations climatiques du passé
éventuellement les causes aussi ce vous
avez tout atteint de données sur
l'évolution du climat il y avait
vraiment des sources d'inquiétude
aujourd'hui et dans les décisions aussi
qui sont prises alors on va peut-être
entrer dans un volet plus politique mais
on a pu voir les accords de paris par
exemple avec la décision des états unis
de donald trump est ce qu'il ya des
inquiétudes à avoir
ben oui bien sûr mais espérons qu en
quelque sorte les sillons de train peu
d'impact comprends pas trop l'effort
mondial associé à la coop 21 ça c'est
sûr personnellement je pense que
l'amérique du moins une partie de
l'amérique parce que tout le monde ne
suit pas la californie je pense ne suit
pas c'est une perte de temps et toute
perte de temps est mauvaise
en fait dans ce domaine maintenant des
climats du passé permettent juste un mot
de mettre en perspective de changement
qui se passe actuellement les
changements qui passe actuellement il
est rapide et d'amplitude importante
aimez-vous qui est justement aux
chercheurs et qui le démontrer par des
faits par des études scientifiques
comment vous pouvez prévoir le fait
qu'aujourd'hui encore tout cela soit
remis en cause parce que c'est un sujet
qui est scientifique mais c'est un sujet
qui a des impacts aussi sociétaux ou des
impacts sociétaux important et dès qu'il
ya des impacts sociétaux
il ya plus seulement la rationalité de
la science si j'ose dire donc ses
classiques être qu'on remette en cause
aussi et justement c'est du coup le
travail aussi d'associations du
collectif comme alternative à
d'expliquer qu' il ya des faits il ya
des preuves voilà scientifique mais pas
d'accord et sculpteur alain c'est à dire
que il ya les faits scientifiques mais
après il peut y avoir il ya l'émotion et
les intérêts et c'est à dire que
bah c'est quand on a des habitudes qui
sont prises c'est difficile de les
remettre en question et aller dire aux
gens de changer
c'est délicat il faut leur montrer que
ce que le changement est enthousiasmant
et donc c'est là en fait la difficulté
et enfin le défi tout à fait relevable
mais voilà il faut il faut avoir une
faire preuve d'intelligence émotionnelle
et s'adapter à l'interlocuteur et
montrer qu'il ya d'autres façons de
faire effectivement comme disait alain
le la californie il ya déjà tout le
monde tous les ai tous les américains ne
s'use pas de nal trump la californie a
menacé de faire sécession
il ya des villes comme san francisco et
qui ont engagé la transition écologique
et ils vont pas lâcher le morceau france
à san francisco c'est une des pionnières
dans la réduction des déchets et c'est
ça qui justement donne à la fois de
l'espoir et l'enthousiasmé qu'il ya des
choses qui se passent malgré le fait
qu'on ait des
d un peu des mines dictateur comme
donald trump quoi sur sur les
conséquences sans avoir un discours
catastrophique mais néanmoins réaliste
sur les conséquences de ces changements
climatiques et disparition des espèces
quelles sont les conséquences que vous
avez pu constater aussi par le passé
alors si vous voulez bien sûr il ya le
changement du climat et plus il va être
important plus il y aura des impacts sur
le vivant sur les espèces
et puis aussi le fait que l'homme en
quelque sorte occupe presque toute la
place disponible sur la planète donc il
ya tout ça donc sur la façon dont vous
travaillez juste on va faire une
parenthèse parce qu'on nous parlait de
l'historique du collectif alternatiba
mais j'ai pas de développer la façon
dont vous vous travaillez moi
personnellement je travaille sur les
sédiments marins qui sont prélevés par
bateau océanographique marion dufresne
et ça nous permet de reconstruire les
variations du climat
vu par l'océan c'est à dire les
changements de l'océan de sa température
est ce qu'il est et stratifié ou mélangé
les changements des courants
donc on regarde tout ça et on le met
aussi en lien avec par exemple ce
qu'obtiennent les collègues qui étudie
les carottes de glace dont on parle
sûrement plus souvent cac40 marine voilà
son travail mais c'est plus de
disciplines scientifiques comme une
autre ensuite on essaye de rédiger des
papiers qui se mit à un regard des
politiques justement ce par rapport à
vos travaux pour justement adapter leurs
politiques adaptées là
les énergies et la façon de fonctionner
j'espère qu'ils tiennent compte de nos
travaux mais nous aux laboratoires ont
fait vraiment des recherches académiques
se taire en public dans des revues
scientifiques internationales
donc on n'a pas d'eau on peut être amené
à interagir un petit peu avec les
politiques certaines personnes jean
jouzel et tout ça mais mais sinon on est
un laboratoire de recherche académique
et on essaye avec tous les collègues de
la communauté de faire avancer la
compréhension du système pour mieux
anticiper ce qui risque d'avenir
d'advenir dans le futur en fonction des
différents scénarios socio économique
c'est à dire est ce qu'on va modérer les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre où est
ce qu'on va rien faire
voilà on essaye d'anticiper si on
parlait des différents sans parler des
états unis avec la techno les décisions
françaises qui sont pris sur plan
technologique le fait de faire
disparaître le gasoil par exemple
quelque chose que alors le gazole
oui enfin ça va prendre du temps et
enfin fait lucide je parlais avant de
sortir des énergies fossiles ou
nucléaires mais ça va prendre du temps
le démentent et une centrale nucléaire
ça va prendre du temps donc il faut
voilà il faut être déterminé je veux
dire un mot sur le gasoil encore une
fois moi ce que je pense c'est que
effectivement on a trop utiliser le
gasoil en particulier en ville parce que
effectivement il ya des polluants même
s'il ya des progrès notables avec les
filtres à particules tout ça on note
on a trop en quelque sorte par des
taxations différentes encourager le
gasoil et des gens qui en quelque sorte
aurait mieux fait de rouler à l'essence
qui font des petits trajets en ville
du coup on roulait à au gasoil donc de
rééquilibrer les taxes personnellement
je pense que c'est plutôt une bonne idée
ou dix on a tous rêvé d un agneau et en
fait j'ai eu une discussion intéressante
avec un architecte qui m'a ramené une
anecdote assez frappante
aujourd'hui le temps que vous mettez
pour traverser paris en voiture c'est le
même temps qui a 100 ans pour traverser
paris avec une carriole tirée par un
cheval
donc tout ça pour ça donc ça fausse
question quoi pourquoi enfin pourquoi
s'encombrer de voitures particulières
dans une grande ville quoi et là
justement où on a trop utiliser ces
énergies lindon il ya d'autres
initiatives qui se met en place
exemple concret ce sera le dernier
reportage de 7,8 société pour ce mois ci
la ligne 23 du réseau phébus qui relie
vélizy à versailles a un nouvel arrivant
un bus 100 % électrique il a été conçu
par alstom
il a été lancé à la fin du mois de
septembre pour une phase de test qui va
durer toute une année le reportage 12
mètres de long 2 100 km d'autonomie et
des allures de tramway la mobilité
s'offre une nouveauté plus écologique
dans les yvelines 100% électrique
ce bus pourra transporter une centaine
de voyageurs les premiers et parmi eux
le maire de versailles sont plutôt combi
est là tous les
les aspects d'un wagon de travaux c'est
à dire des fenêtres qui sont plus basses
aucune visibilité parfaite sur
l'extérieur le tramway c'était très
séduisant jeu guerrier ya dix ans mais
aujourd'hui la vraie modernité c'est
d'avoir les avantages du tramway avec
les avantages du bus et là on en a la
démonstration est donc on est très
contents de servir de lieu de
démonstration un lieu de démonstration
qui s'étend de vélizy à versailles sur
la ligne 23 du réseau fébus conçu par
alstom ce bus nommé à petit ce est une
concrétisation de la région
ile-de-france en faveur des transports
c'est la région qui a à travers
ile-de-france mobilité qui a investi
dans ce premier prototype puisque pour
l'instant c'est qu'un prototype on a la
chance de l'avoir pendant un an un en
test grandeur nature c'est un
investissement de 600 mille euros équipé
d'une dizaine de packs batteries le bus
et recharger tous les soirs son
originalité ses quatre roues directrices
à l'avant et à l'arrière
elle change la conduite par rapport à un
bus classique mana ori analyse sa prise
en main pour former les futurs
conducteurs
il va faire un gros temps d'adaptation
aux conducteurs pour le prendre en main
parce qu'on n'a pas du tout la même le
même positionnement sur la chaussée dû
au fait que les roues sont sunu le
cockpit conducteur est légèrement décalé
vers un milieu du coup on se positionne
pas de la même manière sur ligne droite
si le test est concluant les premières
livraisons de ce modèle auront lieu en
2019 pour l'après vélo électrique en bus
électriques
tout ça va dans le bon sens super un
petit message d'optimisme à la fin de
cette fuite société et qui était
consacrée au changement climatique et
aux défis énergétiques avec ce
documentaire consacré à bertrand piccard
que vous avez pu découvrir au début de
cette émission nous allons refermer ce
7,8 société merci à vous deux merci
également à vous de nous avoir suivis je
propose de revoir ses michettes émission
dès à présent sur notre site internet ou
encore via notre application mobile les
programmes se poursuivre sur tv 78 à
très bientôt
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]